[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal a préparé par
les équipes de tv 78 nous sommes le
lundi 16 mai au sommaire aujourd'hui
le la page pierre bédier se tourne à
mantes la jolie le président du conseil
départemental a vu la liste qu'il
soutenait se faire battre dès le premier
tour par celle de son ancien protégé à
graf sahel cogner lors de l'élection
municipale partielle les réactions à
l'issue du scrutin à suivre toujours en
politique à moins d'un mois du premier
tour des élections législatives nous
faisons le point sur les enjeux du
scrutin à venir à dans les yvelines pour
ce premier volet focus sur la première
circonscription
et puis depuis le mois d'avril la pluie
se fait rare et les agriculteurs qu'on
passe à une période de sécheresse
comment faire face des exploitations
agricoles nous ont ouvert leurs portes
un représentant de la chambre
d'agriculture d'île de france sera avec
nous pour faire le point
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce dimanche 15 mai l'aimanté mantaise
étaient appelés aux urnes pour élire
leur nouveau maire lors de la municipale
partielle à mantes la jolie et c'est
finalement rappelle cogné le maire
démissionnaire a qui a pris sa revanche
il est réélu au premier tour avec 51%
des voix à nicolas d'ambri mathilde
francou
[Applaudissements]
c'est historique jean luc santini le
candidat soutenu par le président du
département est évincé dès le premier
tour de la municipale partielle dans son
fief à mantes la jolie après une
campagne tendue ce dernier totalise que
35 74% des suffrages s'il n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer pierre bédier a
réagi sur les réseaux le peuple a
toujours raison c'est le principe de
l'élection un seul voeu qu'il ait eu
vraiment raison seul l'avenir nous dira
si un ambitieux sans scrupules et dont
la nouvelle équipe découvrir à l'égoïsme
peut faire un élu jouant collectif et
dévoués au bien public et si toutes les
promesses individuelles et générales
seront tenues la suite au prochain
épisode
il n'y aura donc pas de second tour
puisque raphaël cogner obtient 51% des
voix c'est lui qui était soutenu par
pierre bédier en 2020 puis poussé vers
la sortie en janvier dernier s'émancipe
et prend sa revanche on est toujours
surpris quand on gagne dès le premier
tour parce que les montées sont
exigeants et donc ils vous donnent pas
leur confiance facilement donc oui c'est
une très grande fierté mais je sais que
cette victoire je la dois au travail que
j'ai fait mais aussi à toute mon équipe
donc je veux vraiment remercier tous les
habitants de mantes la jolie pour leur
confiance pour ce premier tour le taux
de participation s'est élevé à 42 49 %
c'est plus qu'en 2020 ou seulement 27,54
% des électeurs s'étaient déplacés aux
urnes pour les municipales
les autres candidats ont félicité le
nouveau maire écoutez ce résultat c'est
avant tout
d'une manière générale bon ben c'est
la fri du
en tout cas apparents du système bédié
moi je suis plutôt satisfait que le
système bédié tombe parce que c'est un
système clientéliste et communautariste
qui a pourri les relations et les la
façon de fonctionner ici sur mantes la
jolie leur est dorénavant au travail
pour dessiner les quatre prochaines
années de la ville ma petite expérience
politique fait que je sais très bien que
les soirs de victoire son histoire qu'il
faut savourer parce que les difficultés
commencent dès lendemain cette ville est
une ville dans lequel on a beaucoup de
difficultés économiques sociales
éducatives et je sais que le travail qui
nous attend est immense mais avec
l'équipe que j'ai la confiance des
habitants de mantes la jolie je suis sûr
qu'on va réussir mais il faut qu'on soit
tous ensemble
[Applaudissements]
et toujours en politique à moins d'un
mois du premier tour des élections
législatives et ce jusqu'au 12 juin nous
vous proposons de faire le point
circonscription par circonscription sur
ce scrutin à venir à dans les yvelines
wilfrid richy rédacteur en chef de télé
78 c'est avec vous que nous allons
commencer bonsoir un soir justin ayant
débuté par la première circonscription
forcément montigny le bretonneux
guyancourt la majorité de versailles ça
c'est pour la délimitation géographique
de cette 1ère circonscription des
yvelines je vais vous épargner la
délimitation à la rue près ça prête
forcément à sourire
la découpage se fait au beau milieu
d'une commune quoi qu'il en soit sur le
plan électoral est cette première
circonscription a toujours penché sous
la vème république
elle vers la droite vers le centre droit
si on exclut tout de même le scrutin de
2010 est qui a vu donc la victoire de la
république en marche face à l'ump la
victoire de cours d'une courte tête 1 51
06 pour didier baichère contre le
républicain françois-xavier bellamy et
pour cette élection 2022 le castle
change alors tout d'abord exit et didier
baichère le sortant pour la majorité
présidentielle c'est une demi surprise
de voir ce marcheur de la première heure
qui s'est notamment attaqué durant son
mandat au sujet sensible de la
reconnaissance faciale être remplacé une
demi surprise car il le dit lui même il
s'est émancipé une ou deux fois à des
votes de son groupe à l'assemblée il
semble accueillir la nouvelle avec du
recul il soutient ouvertement sur ces
réseaux celui qui brigue sa succession
et il s'appelle charles rodwell et
charles bedouelle c'est pas forcément un
nom qui parle à tous les yvelines walsh
hardwell c'est un adjoint au maire de
versailles chargé de la jeunesse ils
portent l'étiquette renaissance le
nouveau nom de la république en marche
il était depuis l an dernier conseiller
en discours bruno le maire parallèlement
à sa carrière chez edf si on remonte
encore un peu on constate aussi qu'il a
travaillé aux côtés de franck riester
lorqu'il lorsqu'il était député il fait
donc partie de cette génération de
collaborateurs ministériels macro nist
qui se voient récompensés par des
investitures et récompensé vous l'avez
dit mais ce qu'il pourrait remporter ce
scrutin alors une tâche que même plus
difficile qu'il n'y paraît déjà parce
qu'en 2017 la victoire cet effet d'une
courte tête et puis dans cette ville de
versailles si on regarde pour les
présidentielles eric zemmour a totalisé
un peu plus de 18% des suffrages dès le
premier tour et les tarifs deuxième
derrière emmanuel macron et puis dans la
ville d'à côté qui fait aussi partie de
cette circonscription celle de
guyancourt jean luc mélenchon lui a
totalisé 35 % et il est arrivé devant
emmanuel macron les deux candidats en
tout cas qui peuvent bénéficier de cet
élan ce sont sébastien ramage pour
lannux lanuf plus à comme vous voulez
cette alliance et puylaurens rochus pour
reconquête également le premier est
engagé au sein de la france insoumise
conseiller municipal de guyancourt la
seconde a été conseillère départementale
des yvelines jusqu'en 2000 à 21 son
mouvement sens commun qui a été ensuite
rebaptisée mouvement conservateur était
alors alliée avec l'ump depuis lé sa
formation océan pris leurs distances ils
se sont alliés avec eric zemmour après
la défaite d'eric ciotti lors de la
primaire de la droite c'est la frange la
plus dure de la droite on se souvient
aussi que pour ses débuts en politique
laurence rochât avait milité au sein de
la manif pour tous et donc elles sont
finalement les autres candidats qui se
présentent dans cette circonscription
alors tout d'abord du côté républicain
autre conseiller municipal de versailles
qui se présentent olivier de la faire
également au conseiller départemental
était candidat à l'investiture de son
parti déjà lui en 2017 non mais vous
l'aviez compris à l'époque il avait été
battu par françois xavier bellamy qui
lui avait été préféré et puis on notera
aussi la présence d'une candidate du
parti animalistes ou encore d'un
candidat de lutte aux ouvrières et puis
aussi une surprise un pour le
rassemblement national à la candidate
anne jacquemin est épaulé par bruno
gollnisch en tant que suppléant il a
déjà siégé dans l'hémicycle attention
c'était entre 86 et 88 justin pour la
circonscription du rom il a surtout été
vice président du front national et puis
s était l'artisan de la campagne de
jean-marie le pen en 2002 il est de
retour en politique avec quelques années
de plus en tant que suppléant dans notre
circonscription de versailles là aussi
un parachutage mais ce n'est pas le seul
on pourrait en parler des heures sur
cette antenne aussi en tout cas on en a
on en a parlé pour l'instant et c'est
très bien du coup le scrutin à 12 et 19
juin merci beaucoup il terrifie d'avoir
été avec nous rédacteur en chef de tv 78
et demain mercredi focus sur la 2e
circonscription des yvelines dans votre
journal local
un tour du côté de la 9e circonscription
avec cette information babette de
rozières ancien soutien de valérie
pécresse entend
se présenter sous plusieurs étiquettes
parmi lesquelles celles de la majorité
nationale présidentielle pardon elle
ferait face à bruno milian seul candidat
officiellement investi ce dernier a
réagi via un communiqué le député
sortant lui demande notamment de retirer
sa candidature pour ne pas faire
opposition il soutenir le programme dans
cette circonscription
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre avec des
températures élevées depuis plusieurs
jours et une météo clémente depuis
plusieurs semaines les agriculteurs font
face à une période de sécheresse
inquiétante complexité dans le
développement des cultures avec des
pertes de rendement à envisager ou
manque de nourriture pour les élevages à
nous en parlerons dans un instant avec
christophe diot à chef du service
agronomie de la chambre d'agriculture
ile de france juste avant je vous
propose de découvrir les exemples de
deux exploitations yvelinoise l'une à
montfort l'amaury l'autre arrosé c'est
avec nicolas landry des gouttes de pluie
de la nuit sur les épis de blé
insuffisant pour compenser l'épisode de
sécheresse de ces dernières semaines
actuellement les cultures agricoles
subissent le manque d'eau notamment
cette parcelle de blé planté durant
l'automne les pieds en train de sortir
de la gaine est donc le blé le grain est
en train de se remplir et donc là on a
dix quinze jours d'avancé par rapport à
une année normale et donc c'est à ce
moment là les plantes ont besoin de plus
et de l'eau dans le sol et des éléments
nutritifs pour pouvoir faire un des
grains bien remplie c'est déjà une perte
de rendement qui est qui a tendu donc
sur mon exploitation en attend entre 10
et 20% pour ces féveroles se met au mois
de mars la sécheresse du sol a des
conséquences sur son développement
c'est une culture actuellement en
souffrance qu'ils veulent a half et 10
cm 10 15 cm de haut elle devrait faire
le double dans cette ferme arroser la
problématique est différente ici des
vaches laitières sont élevés du lait
destiné à la production de fromage et de
yaourts la sécheresse n'impacte pas
directement les bêtes mais leur
alimentation jeunes leur donner de la
luzienne issue de la première coupe
cette année que l'inquiétude allait
point sur la première coupe je pense pas
non plus vraiment sur la deuxième puis
ce qu'on va faire la deux m au 15 juin
ce qui est pas si loin que ça la
troisième coupe qui prévu au 1er août à
mon avis s'il pleut pas ça va pas du
cran
on a facilement deux tiers de production
- ici la nourriture des bovins et
cultivés dans les champs en face de la
luzerne cette parcelle permet de
cultiver du foin dans un mois et demi
c'est en paillasson surtout si on fait
les foins donc ça repousse pas parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'eau et on est obligé
de donner ce qu'on a récolté donc taper
sur les stocks qu'on avait prévu pour
l'hiver au mois d'août on est obligé
d'acheter de la paille des budgets de
racheter du foin donc économiquement
plus viable et c'est la catastrophe
sur les 90 hectares de cette
exploitation 30 sont consacrés à la
culture de l'escourgeon une orge planté
qui nécessite de l'eau pour la fin de
son développement si j'ai 40 mm le plus
dur est dédé
des paysans bien sûr mon ange va faire
du grain bien lourd je vais avoir du
foie et puis mes deuxièmes troisièmes
coupe de luzerne vont être sauvés météo
france prévoit de la pluie à partir de
jeudi jusqu'à vendredi soir
et pour approfondir la sécheresse et ses
conséquences ce sujet christophe dion
vous êtes avec nous vous nous avez
rejoint à je le rappelle vous êtes chef
du service agronomie de la chambre
d'agriculture d'ile-de-france bonsoir
bonsoir on vient de le voir dans ce
reportage nous faisons face un épisode
de sécheresse je voulais déjà voir avec
vous ou est-ce qu'on en ait dans les
yvelines par rapport au territoire
national finalement alors dans les
yvelines on est comme une grosse partie
du territoire national on avait eu une
quarantaine de mm sur les dix premiers
jours du mois d'avril et depuis on n'a
pratiquement rien eu sauf hier soir
quelques secteurs du territoire des
yvelines en gros sur ces deux mois donc
avril et mai on attend en général autour
de 100 à 120 mm d'eau et d'un on est à
peu près autour de 40 mm vous voyez que
le déficit était très important à une
période de toutes les cultures qui ont
été implantés à l'automne sont en train
de fabriquer leurs grains et donc ont
besoin d'eau avoir quantité de grains
suffisante et une qualité suffisant et
justement là on est au mois de mai le
temps on va devenir normalement de plus
en plus sec comment on peut faire face
dans les mois à venir quel pourrait être
l'impact à long terme il a écouté les
agriculteurs qui ont de l'irrigation ont
déjà mis en route un mais c'est sur le
territoire des yvelines c'est loin
d'être la majorité des agriculteurs une
très grosse majorité ne sont pas équipés
et sinon on attend la pluie mais les
mesures à prendre dans l'urgence est
donc à court terme sont extrêmement
fiable
là on l'a dit à vous représenter la
chambre d'agriculture donc de la région
ile de france vous quel est votre rôle
et comment finalement vous pouvez les
accompagner à ses agriculteurs bad on
est professionnel justement dans cet
épisode de sécheresse ben on a une
activité de conseil auprès d'eux
malheureusement c'est parce qu'il fait
tomber la pluie mais on peut orienter un
petit peu les programmes techniques sur
les cultures en général quand il fait
c'est qu'il ya moins de maladies donc on
intervient un peu moins contre la lutte
contre les maladies des petites choses
comme ça et on travaille aussi sur le
long terme parce qu'on sait
malheureusement de ces épisodes d'accous
climatiques vont se se multiplier et
donc on travaille nous sur les choix
d'espèces le choix de variétés plus
tolérantes à la sécheresse une sorte
d'adaptation qui va permettre aux
agriculteurs de
pallier en partie parce que ce ne sera
qu'en partie les effets de ce
réchauffement c'est des températures
qu'on a actuellement c'est quelque chose
qu'on a quasiment jamais vu aussi
longtemps et aussi fort au mois de mai
parce que justement vous vous observez
vous une évolution de ces épisodes de
sécheresse au fil des ans oui on
s'aperçoit en fait que les frais sont
plus en plus nombreux même si la
quantité d'eau global sur l'année est à
peu près stable
en fait ce qui change c'est la
répartition au cours de l'année on a
maintenant des épisodes de pluies
importantes et à contrario des épisodes
de pluie de sécheresse pardon qui sont
lus eux aussi vous de bien plus
important est bien plus long qu
historiquement
plus globalement on va parler un peu du
coût du réchauffement climatique
s'inquiètent de plus en plus il ya déjà
d'énormes impacts on le sait on parle
notamment de stocker peut-être plus
d'eau en amont pour pour l'agriculture
est ce que c'est vraiment une solution
selon vous est ce qu'il faudrait
repenser finalement l'agriculture et le
modèle d'exploitation française alors
les il n'y a pas une seule solution il y
en aura forcément plusieurs est évident
que le stockage de l'eau quand elle est
très abondant est un facteur on va
essayer de mettre en oeuvre on a tous
connu des épisodes d'inondations et
pendant ces périodes là il faut aussi de
stocker de l'eau il faut des ouvrages
pour ça donc ça c'est une première liste
une seconde est d'avoir des cultures un
peu moins exigeantes en eau on travaille
notamment nous dans les yvelines a
remplacé une partie du maïs par du 100
euros en collaboration avec des
organismes de collecte
voilà certain nombre de pistes qui sont
qui sont travaillés par rapport à ce
réchauffement climatique une dernière
question peut être avant de vous quitter
il ya une ferme laboratoire par exemple
qui a été lancée en 2020 dans le
département de l'essonne elle utilise
l'agroécologie est-ce que c'est vers ces
nouvelles pratiques finalement qu'on
pourrait se tourner aujourd'hui
par rapport aux changements climatiques
et par rapport à la pluie l'agroécologie
ne change pas à grand chose
c'est un système de culture est impec
plus de culture légèrement plus
résilient mais par rapport au manque
d'eau qu'on soit dans un système de ce
type là ou dans un autre il ya
relativement peu à peu et puis vous avez
aussi des exportations comme les
exploitations maraîchères par exemple
qui eux ont forcément besoin
d'irrigation au sec dans les yvelines
quelque chose d'important il ya un
certain nombre de maraîchers qui
produisent pas mal de légumes pour les
yvelinois
on a aussi des les arboriculteurs
qu'est-ce qu'ils tiendront un peu pour
leurs cultures
passées à l'image des frais dans les
fraises sotiri guerre c'est très c'est
évidemment très important pour tout ce
qui est production légumière pas
forcément une solution l'agroécologie
mais pourtant il faut employer dont vous
m'avez dit plusieurs solutions pour
régler le problème
merci beaucoup christophe dion d'avoir
été avec nous un je le rappelle vous
êtes chef du service agronomie de la
chambre d'agriculture d'île de france
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
et l'assemblée générale de la fdsea
fédération départementale
des syndicats d'exploitants agricoles
aura lieu demain mardi 17 mai à
palaiseau dans le département de
l'essonne et des échanges sont prévus
durant la matinée des discussions autour
de la place de l'agriculture française
dans le monde à ce sujet qui fait écho à
l'actualité notamment avec le conflit en
ukraine
et la maison de l'europe des yvelines
était la semaine dernière en déplacement
à varsovie en pologne dans le cadre du
projet gira dont green initiatives
rurales alors excusez moi pour mon
accent l'occasion de débattre et
échanger s'informer sur des pratiques
plus vertes avec d'autres délégations
présentes animé un atelier lors de la
journée de l'europe le 7 mais également
le reportage de matisse godefroy qui
s'est rendu sur place
en premier lieu apprendre à se connaître
six délégations venues de toute l'europe
ont répondu présentes à l'appel de la
fondation schuman de varsovie pour
échanger autour du développement durable
dans les zones rurales une problématique
importante ici en pologne
nous allons voir des entreprises
sociales à la campagne qui utilisent
d'anciennes techniques pour travailler
avec des fruits et des légumes et qui
engage les populations locales des zones
rurales cette réunion ce projet sont
organisées pour les personnes des
différentes délégations qui ont des
fonctionnements différents mais qui ont
un projet commun sauver et protéger
notre planète
au programme de ce déplacement des
rencontres mais aussi des visites comme
dans ce village de poterie qui a permis
de redynamiser le secteur en faisant
s'impliquer davantage les habitants
depuis une quinzaine d'années un un
village qui était quasiment mort à créer
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui
animations à la fois écologiques à la
fois touristique qui montre que ces
petits villages ces petits endroits
permettent depuis maintenant avec une
volonté de quelqu'un d'un groupe à faire
quelque chose l'étape finale de ce
voyage dans le webzine qui parquent de
la capitale polonaise pour le jour de
l'europe un événement important pour se
réunir et parler d'europe c'est
important de parler d'europe tout le
temps partout on a vu une accélération
il ya des choses qui se sont passées qui
ne se serait jamais passé s'il n'y avait
pas eu copie de le fait d'acheter des
masques collectivement d'organiser la
vaccination etc si chaque et avait dû le
faire individuellement ça aurait pas eu
le même le même effet le même impact
prochaine étape du projet dira pour nos
six délégations la suède au mois de juin
prochain
et c'est le premier événement de la
sorte les entreprises par partage
leicester europe se sont associés à pour
créer une journée de rencontres mêlant
professionnels du bâtiment et monde
artistique est le tout au golf 2
bêtement à poissy et céline charles
s'est rendu sur place regarder
associer la culture au business à
travers le sport c'était l'objectif que
s'étaient fixés les entreprises art
partage esther europe lors de
l'événement swing art cup au total une
soixantaine d'architectes bailleurs
sociaux élus locaux ou encore promoteurs
se sont rencontrés au golf de bêtement
au programme initiation au golf pour les
débutants parcours pour les plus initiés
et déambulation à travers les stands de
plusieurs artistes on s'est dit mais est
en fait il n'ya jamais eu d'événements
qui mélangeait l'art et l'architecturé
le bâti et le monde du bâtiment c'est
vrai que moi je dis je répète souvent
que dans architecture les trois
premières lettres c1 et les architectes
sont avant tout des artistes mais dans
les événements du bâtiment on ne voit
jamais d'artistes s'exprimer en tant
qu'artiste donc l'idée c'était de
mélanger seulement ce monde la volonté
c'est vraiment de de dire ben voilà
c'est un événement qui est différent qui
est inédit mais surtout avec la culture
on a on donne quelques petites clés de
ce que l'on pourrait faire pour vos
entreprises dans le monde du bâtiment
dans la construction avec les salariés
objectif permettre aux invités de se
faire des contacts dans un cadre ludique
convivial est différent des salons
traditionnels
portraitiste artistes peintres ou encore
photographes ont répondu présent un
trophée a également été dessinée par un
créateur sculpteur plasticien et remis
aux trois gagnants ils choisissaient
leurs casquettes customisés ensuite ils
allaient voir l'artiste peintre donc ça
permettait des échanges autour d'une
grande toile on avait regroupé
l'ensemble de toutes les casquettes
qu'elle avait réalisé j'ai décidé de
faire un dessin unique pour chaque
casque est donc 66 casquette au niveau
technique rien qu'au niveau du dessin
c'était la première fois que je
dessinais des grues des maisons
de cette façon là voilà j'ai découvert
un peu le milieu du bâtiment aussi à
travers mon travail et c'est super une
journée qui faisait office de test mais
que les organisateurs comptent bien
renouveler l'année prochaine
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver michael et demi d'euros pour
votre magazine sportif à ses côtés
bixente mes liens sont tissés ban pour
vos résultats à du week-end très bonne
soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]